bonjour à tous et à toutes
j'aimerais explorer avec vous ce soir ou
aujourd'hui un sujet qui nous mobilise
tous environ cent mille fois au cours
d'une vie sept jours sur sept
notre assiette alors je pourrai
commencer par vous dire que finalement
manger trop sucrées augmente vos risques
de diabète de surpoids
je pourrais aussi vous dire que manger
trop de pesticides augmente le risque de
cancer en 10 secondes
je vous ai démotivés vous saviez déjà
peut-être mais surtout la nutrition ce
n'est pas ça je préfère plutôt vous
parler de nutrition du bon sens savez
vous que cette pomme est un enjeu
mondial
vous êtes vous déjà demandé d'où venait
cette si elle était bonne pour votre
santé
et finalement que devenait tél
une fois que vous l'aviez croquer dans
quelques heures je vais devenir cette
pomme ou plus exactement cette pomme va
constituer une partie de mes cellules
après un extraordinaire voyage je viens
de la mâche est devant vous elle est
passée dans mon estomac et elle va pas
revenir dans second cerveau mon intestin
vous avez plus de 200 millions de
neurones dans l'intestin soit
l'équivalent d'un cerveau de chien la
façon dont vous mangez influence
directement votre humeur et avez vous
entendu parler du microbiote votre flore
intestinale
en tout cas elle vous parle en
permanence vous avez dix fois plus de
bactéries dans l'intestin que vous
n'avez de cellules dans l'ensemble de
l'organisme et cet écosystème détermine
en partie au risque de diabète vos
risques d'obésité aux infections
et même votre comportement y compris
alimentaires
ces nutriments vont passer dans les 300
mètres carrés de surface de même que
intestinale soual davantage que la
surface d'un terrain de tennis ont pas
revenir dans mon sang est intégré
quelques unes de mes dix mille milliards
de cellules
je deviens alors ce que je mange
cette pomme nous constitue dans
l'infiniment petit sous le contrôle de
mon chef d'orchestre l'apn jusqu'à peu
la science estimait que cette
information fille gitte génétique était
figé à l'histoire
à l'instar de l'histoire d'un livre et
je me rappelle d'une collection de
livres que je dévorais au cours de mon
enfance le livre le livre dont vous êtes
le héros
eh bien j'ai une nouvelle importante
aujourd'hui à vous confiez vous êtes le
principal héros du livre de votre santé
et la science le prouve aujourd'hui à
travers une nouvelle discipline lépi
génétique
l'épigénétique littéralement ce qui est
en dehors de la vie de la génétique
étudie les effets de l'environnement sur
l'expression de nos gènes et on estime
ainsi qu' environ 80% de notre
information génétique peut être modulée
en fonction de notre environnement et en
particulier de ce que nous mangeons de
la façon dont nous bougeons et de la
façon dont nous pensons c'est un petit
peu comme si vous disposiez 2 millions
d'interrupteurs que vous choisiriez
d'activer ou de réprimer en fonction de
votre comportement
pourtant à l'échelle de l'humanité
l'information génétique a très peu
évolué moins de 1% à 1 million den notre
environnement alimentaire quant à lui en
l'espace de 60 ans a subi un véritable
tsunami alimentaire
nos ancêtres de cro magnon
aller cueillir des baies sauvages à les
chasser la viande qui consommaient quand
ils ont trouvé aujourd'hui nous allons
volant notre voiture chercher une pizza
surgelée oodrive
quand on ne la fait pas livré nous ne
mangeons plus nous consommons qui
fusaient des aliments totalement
déconnectée de la terre ces aliments ont
un impact sur toute une série
aujourd'hui de ce qu'on appelle des
pathologies dites de civilisation
maladies cardiovasculaires maladies auto
immunes diabète obésité parkinson cancer
toutes ces maladies ont un point commun
elles dépendent du trépied de votre
santé votre assiette
la façon dont vous bougez et la gestion
des émotions votre assiette
votre tête et vos baskets
voilà le secret de votre santé en effet
vos cellules dispose d'une fabuleuse
capacité d'adaptation permanente à leur
environnement
ce que l'on appelle l'homéostasie
cellulaire jusqu'à un certain stade
quand vous voulez à 130 kilomètres sur
l'autoroute au volant de votre voiture
si un voyant vous rouge s'allume en
toute logique vous allez vous arrêter
identifier la panne la réparer et
repartir progressivement prudemment
votre corps c'est la voiture de votre
semblait quand vous dormez mal quand
vous ne récupérez plus quand vous êtes
soumis à des troubles digestifs
permanent quand vous tombez
régulièrement malade vos cellules ceux
des âmes juste
point d'altérer les fonctions de
certains tissus voire de provoquer ces
pathologies dites de civilisation avoir
recours à la médecine de lentilles tout
anti cholestérol aignan antidiabétique
anti dépresseurs anti inflammatoire anti
hypertenseur revient finalement à
appuyer sur un bouton pour éteindre
voyant rouge même si cette médecine peut
être nécessaire parfois elle ne permet
pas de réparer l'origine de votre panne
au contraire votre alimentation permet
simplement à vos cellules de répondre
favorablement aux adaptations attendu
face à l'environnement d'une manière
générale votre aliment vous éloigne des
médicaments votre assiette est le reflet
de votre santé intérieur ou un apple a
day keeps the doctor away
malheureusement quand on parle de
nutrition aujourd'hui pire de diététique
les premiers mots qui nous viennent à
l'esprit sont en général culpabilisant
moralisateur frustrant régime
personnellement ça fait 20 ans qu'on
n'ose plus ma vie tu es à dîner de peur
ne soit pas savoir quoi même proposé à
dîner mais je suis comme vous j'aime
bien manger
j'aime manger entre amis j'aime boire un
bon verre de vin
alors rassurez vous il ne s'agit pas de
vous imposer un diktat nutritionnelle
vous n'allez pas à courir un marathon
sans vous entraînez auparavant la
nutrition c'est la même chose je vous
propose juste d'impulser en douceur une
évolution alimentaires 2 en 2 ans sont
en moyenne nécessaire pour transformer
ces changements
en reflex alors il serait plus simple
pour moi de vous dire finalement que le
dernier régime à la mode serait le plus
efficace ou que finalement tout n'est
qu'une question de volonté
cette fameuse volonté il ya bientôt
vingt ans je faisais partie de l'équipe
de france juniors de triathlon je
m'entraînais alors avec un cycliste
professionnel qui m'a indiqué que une
pomme comme ça pouvait permettre de
rouler plus de 200km adolescents
soucieux d'optimiser tous les facteurs
de la performance y compris
l'alimentation
quelques mois plus tard je faisais 35 kg
et les médecins ne venez pas deux
semaines à vivre dans cet état
les ja prix plus tard que ce qui ce se
dopait gimmi à peu près 15 ans sans
toucher un vélo sans en faire une
longueur de piscine et puis j'ai
retrouvé le goût de la performance le
plaisir du sport au point de vouloir
préparer à un ironman en deux mois cette
course extrême ce triathlon qui enchaîne
3 km 8 de natation 180 km de vélo et un
marathon 104e 42 km à pied et comme tout
n'est qu'une question de volonté
tout est possible effectivement objectif
réussi en moins de dix heures donc les
spécialistes apprécieront
quelques semaines plus tard nous revoilà
à l'hôpital pour une destruction
généralisée des cellules musculaires
sans aucune explication médicale
quant au troisième très fier de la santé
la gestion des émotions
à force d'aller explorer les états
modifiés de conscience
à l'autre bout du monde j'ai fini par
explorer la méningite
hasard ou pas pourquoi je vous raconte
son histoire
tout simplement parce que
à force d'avoir exploré les extrêmes
j'ai compris que non tout n'est pas
qu'une question de volonté
l'excès peut être l'ennemi du mieux les
régimes drastiques
c'est exactement la même chose
aujourd'hui je dirais qu'il est beaucoup
plus simple de croire en un régime
qu'une modification alimentaire au
contraire c'est régime provoquent très
souvent la désinstallation cellulaire
même si nous nous complaisons a
finalement espérer dans un régime
miracle dans une pilule miracle mais
nous choisissons finalement une démarche
qui serait de considérer
l'anti-inflammatoire de notre
alimentation
prenez par exemple les régimes
amaigrissants
peut-être avez-vous déjà essayé de
maigrir
comme 70 % des femmes 40 % des hommes
quand vous avez pris du poids
progressivement
là aussi vos cellules
ce sondage se sont adaptés
al'inverse si vous cherchez à maigrir
rapidement vous agressez vos cellules
qui vont mettre en place tous les
mécanismes possibles pour revenir à leur
état initial
ce que vous vous considérez al'inverse
comme votre état d'agressions
commence alors un combat entre votre
mental et vos cellules le combat est
perdu d'avancé
sauf au prix d'un contrôle permanent
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui la
l'obésité est considérée comme une
maladie chronique et non simplement
comme un manque de volonté
seul un régime amaigrissant respectueux
de cette fameuse homéostasie cellulaire
dans le plaisir
petit pas par petit pas vous permet de
mincir sur le long terme
nul besoin de régime miracle juste du
bon sens en parlant de bon sens je vous
dis depuis tout à l'heure que vous êtes
le premier acteur de votre santé soit
vous allez donc croquer cette pomme en
bonne conscience persuadée qu'elle est
bonne pour votre santé mais il était
réellement je viens de la croquer en
plein mois de juillet soit de nombreux
mois après sa récolte après qu elle
était conservée en atmosphère modifiée
en l'espace de cinquante ans cette pomme
a perdu jusqu'à 80% de sa teneur en
minéraux
si elle est issue de l'agriculture
conventionnelle
elle aura été en traité en moyenne par
36 pesticides différents
vous avez envie vous de croquer cette
pop dans ces conditions moi non
par ailleurs il y aurait-il finalement
pas une certaine confusion entre ces
recommandations nutritionnelles et les
enjeux environnementaux
cette pomme qui me constitue dans
l'infiniment petit au coeur de mes
cellules influe également sur
l'infiniment grand
la planète éloignée les deux enjeux
principaux que sont les enjeux
nutritionnelle et environnementaux est
un non sens les solutions existent et
elles sont les mêmes elles fleurissent
aux quatre coins du monde
prenons par exemple la permaculture la
permaculture est un modèle de culture
qui permet de favoriser un écosystème où
chaque composant intéresse
favorablement avec les autres composants
la nature est de la nature qui est de
l'homme
non seulement cette culture a démontré
sa rentabilité économique mais elle
permet par ailleurs d'augmenter la
densité nutritionnelle des végétaux elle
transforme des calories vides de
micronutriments en calories plein revoir
nos choix nutritionnels permet également
de réduire l'empreinte hydrique environ
700 litres d'eau ont été nécessaires
pour cultiver 6,6 pomme comme celle-ci
2400 pour fabriquer le plus célèbre des
hamburgers quand il est consommé
quarante et une tonne d'aliments sont
jetés chaque seconde
depuis que je vous parle 25000 tonnes
alors que faire quoi manger à l'échelle
collectif nous devons reconsidérer
l'intégralité de la chaîne alimentaire
de cette pomme est bien entendu de
l'ensemble des aliments selon une
approche globale holistique qui
répondent autant aux enjeux nutritionnel
aux enjeux environnementaux la culture
l'élevage la production la
transformation la distribution la
consommation la qualité de notre
alimentation donc de notre santé mérite
bien mieux qu'une simple considération
économique même si elle doit être prise
en compte
c'est d'ailleurs aujourd'hui le sujet de
mes recherches que de prouver ces
éléments là à l'échelle individuelle
vous
et tout entre les mains vous avez la
fabuleuse opportunité en moyenne trois
fois par jour de décider ce que vous
voulez mettre dans votre assiette
vous pouvez décider d'une alimentation
fraîche non transformé locale qui
empruntent des circuits courts apprendre
comprendre ce qu'est l'alimentation ce
qu'est la nutrition réapprendre le
plaisir de cuisiner des aliments
directement issus de la terre avec nos
enfants dans le plaisir et en conscience
à l'image du colibri agir à titre
individuel pour une démarche collective
qu'avez-vous à gagner juste de retrouver
votre vitalité physique et intellectuel
juste de gérer naturellement votre
plateforme juste de vous éloigner de ces
fameuses maladies de civilisation
je vous propose d'être le héros du livre
de votre santé mais aussi de celle de
vos enfants et de la planète
unir l'infiniment petit au coeur de nos
cellules avec l'infiniment grand
la planète donc je vous invite ce soit à
explorer votre assiette et à la voir
comme une fabuleuse opportunité de
prendre soin de vous et dans l'
équilibre
merci